I want to take up in volume 12 in January the 24th 1921.
We're going to be talking about the third fiat for a long time now.
The third fiat will bring to completion the glory and the honor of the fiat of creation.
And the three fiats will veil the most holy trinity on earth.
It is very important teaching now.
Louisa said she was feeling annihilated in thinking about this fiat of the Lord.
"But beloved Jesus wanted to increase her confusion," she said.
"It seems that he wants to make fun of me, proposing to me astonishing and most incredible things,
taking pleasure in seeing me confused and more annihilated."
And what is worse is that I am forced by obedience to write them to my greater torment.
So, while I was praying, my sweet Jesus leaned his head against mine, sustaining his forehead
with his hand, and a light coming from his forehead told me.
Now this light, this is infused knowledge coming directly from his intellect to hers.
My daughter, he said, "The first fiat was pronounced in creation with no intervention
of the creature, naturally because we weren't there."
The second fiat was pronounced in redemption.
I wanted the intervention of the creature, so I chose my mother for the completion of the second fiat.
Now, for the fulfillment of both the first and the second, I wanted to pronounce the third fiat.
And I want to pronounce it through you.
"I have chosen you," he said to Louisa, "for the fulfillment of the third fiat."
This third fiat will bring to completion the glory and the honor of the fiat of creation.
And it will be the confirmation and the development of the fruits of the fiat of redemption.
These three fields will veil the most holy trinity on earth.
And I will have the fiat belong to us on earth as it is in heaven.
These three three vietts will be inseparable. Each one will be the life of the other.
They will be one and triune, just as God himself is one and triune.
They will be distinct among themselves, just as the three persons of the most holy trinity
are distinct among themselves.
"My love wants it," my glory demands it, he said.
"Having unleashed the first two fiats from the womb of my creative power,
it wants to unleash the third fiat because my love can no longer contain it,
so it's time for that love to be poured out."
And this in order to complete the work which came from me, otherwise the works of creation
and of redemption would be incomplete and God is not able to do something that isn't complete.
On hearing this, Louisa said, "I was not only confused but stunned
and I said to myself, 'It's all this possible. There are so many.'
And if it is true that he has chosen me, she means there are so many other holy people.
If it's true that he has chosen me, it seems to me that this is one of the usual follies of Jesus.
And then what could I do or say from within a bed half crippled and inept as I am?
How could I ever keep up with the multiplicity and infinity of the fiat of creation and of redemption
and yet she will do it marvelously when we go on in the higher volumes?
Since my fiat is similar to the other two fiats,
I must run together with them, multiply myself with them, do the good which they do, braid myself
with them. Jesus think of what you are doing." She said, "I'm not this much, but who can tell
all the nonsense that I was saying?" And then Jesus came back and told her, "My daughter,
Cam yourself, I choose whomever I please." This is perfectly clear in Romans 11,
verses 5 to 6 and in Romans 9, verses 19 to 21. The clay cannot say to the potter,
'Why did you not choose me?' Or, 'I want to be different.'
I choose whomever I please. However, know that I begin all of my works between myself and one
creature and then they are spread. In fact, who was the first spectator of the fiat of creation?
It was Adam and then Eve. It surely wasn't a multitude of people. Only after years and years
did crowds and multitudes of people become spectators of it. In the second fiat,
my mother was the only spectator, not even Saint Joseph knew anything. At my mother found herself
more than in your condition. The greatness of the creative power of my work which she felt within
herself was such that confounded she did not feel the strength to mention it to anybody else.
And if then Saint Joseph found out about it, it was because I manifested it to him.
So, this fiat,
so this fiat germinated like a seed within her virginal womb. The ear of the grain was
formed in order to multiply it and then it came to the light of day. But who were the spectators?
Very few. In the room of Nazareth, now notice how small the house was. In the room of Nazareth,
my dear mother and Saint Joseph were the only spectators. Then, when my most holy humanity grew up,
I went out and I made myself known, but not to everyone.
Afterwards, it spread more and it will still spread because not everybody knows about redemption
yet. And so, the third fiat will be like this. It will germinate within you, the ear of grain
will be formed, only the priest will have knowledge of it and then a few souls and then it will spread.
It will spread and it will follow the same path as creation and redemption. The more crushed you feel,
the more the ear of the third fiat grows and is fertilized in you. Therefore, be attentive
and be faithful. So, I want to give you John 12-24, unless the grain of wheat falls into the ground
and dies, it will only remain a grain of wheat. But if it allows itself to die, it will bear much fruit.
So, February the 2nd, 1921. The third fiat must run together with the other two.
Continuing my usual state, Louisa said, I was fusing all of myself in the divine volition.
I said to myself, my Jesus, I want to love you and I want so much love as to compensate for
the love of all generations which have been and whichever will be. But who can give me so much love
to be able to love for all? My love in your will, my love, she said, in your will there is the
creative power and therefore in your will I myself want to create. Look at the words she's saying
because there's the creative power so you can create. She wants to create as much love
as to compensate for and surpass the love of all and all that creatures are obliged to give to God
our Creator. In the divine will we can use that creative power to create enough forgiveness
for all humanity so that all war will stop. We can create enough humility for the human race
to bend its knee before the living God. Can't you see we have the answer?
While I was doing this, she said, Jesus came and moved in her interior and told her,
my daughter surely in my will there is the creative power. Billions and billions of stars
came out from one single fiat, billions and billions of acts of grace
which communicate themselves to souls came out of the fiat miki sikondum verbum tuum
of my holy mother from which redemption has its origin. These acts of grace are more beautiful,
more shining, more varied than the stars and where the stars are fixed and do not multiply
the acts of grace do multiply to infinity and they run in every instant attract souls, delight
them, strengthen them and give them life. If souls could see the supernatural order of grace
they would hear such harmony and they would see such enchanting scenes as to believe that they were
in paradise. Now the third fiat too must run together with the other two fiots. It must multiply
to infinity and in every instant. It must give as many acts for as many acts of grace as are
unleashed from my womb, for as many stars for as many drops of water, for as many created things
as were unleashed in the fiat of creation. It must blend with them and say as many acts as you are
so many I do. So whatever number of acts were done in creation and redemption must be done
in the fiat of sanctification. These three acts have the same value and the same power.
You disappeared Jesus said to Louisa. It is the fiat that acts and therefore you too can say
in my omnipotent fiat I want to create so much love, so many adoration to cover all the adoration
that human beings ought to give to the Lord. I want to create so many blessings so that the
Lord is blessed by every soul from Adam to Zachary. I want to create so much glory to my God as to
compensate for everyone and everything. Look how beautiful it is. Your acts will fill heaven and
earth and they will multiply themselves with the acts of creation as the Father, the acts of redemption
the Son and they will become one with the acts of the Holy Spirit. All this may seem astonishing
and incredible to some people. In this case they would have to doubt about my creative power
because nothing is impossible with God. I mean nothing is impossible with God.
That's why when we go into the divine will we find all power and all possibility.
At this moment we can go into the creative divine will of God, fuse ourselves with him as I do now
and I want to create as much healing as we'll cover every single person on the earth and overcome
this coronavirus. He will do it in his creative power. He is healing. He is life.
The virus cannot stand up to him.
So all this may seem astonishing and incredible to some but in this case they would have to doubt
my creative power and besides when it is I who wants it and who gives the power every doubt ceases.
In the miracles of Jesus I've said this to you before he sometimes simply said to the person
I want it and if God wants it that's it. It becomes a reality. Am I perhaps not free to do what I want?
There's your Romans 11, 33 to 36 and to give to whomever I want. You must be attentive Jesus
said I will be with you and I will overshadow you with my creative power and I will accomplish,
I will accomplish what I want upon you. Now that overshadowing of the Holy Spirit you'll see it in
Luke chapter 1 verse 35 at the incarnation for our blessed mother and you will see it on Mount
Tabor in Matthew 17 5 when the three apostles who were privileged to see the divinity of Jesus
at that moment they were overshadowed by the presence of God as well. So February the 8th 1921
while the world wants to cast Jesus away from the face of the earth he is preparing an era of love
for them the era of the third fiat. So you've got human beings going towards evil and you have
the Lord creating enormous incredible incalculable good for them while they're doing it.
So now you know who God is. God is love. Jesus said oh iniquitous world you are doing everything
you can to cast me away from the face of the earth. This is 1921 and atheistic communism
and atheistic materialism is having a field day destroying whole countries in the USSR and spreading
out into Europe. Of course it didn't start there. Atheistic materialism really came to the surface
in France during the French Revolution and France was called the eldest daughter of the church.
How could such evil come from the eldest daughter of the church?
They want to cast me away from the face of the earth to banish me from society, from schools,
from conversations, from everything. Even here in Ireland they've taken the crucifixes down from our
walls. They won't leave any sign of Christianity in our hospitals or our schools and they make
lame excuses about it. That's banishing the Lord. You are plotting how to demolish temples and
altars. Of course that was happening in the USSR at the time that Jesus was speaking. You want to
destroy my church and kill my ministers which they did in their thousands. While I am preparing
for you an era of love, an era of my third fiat, you will do whatever you do to banish me and I
will confound you by means of love. So love will conquer fear, love will conquer hate. That's why
in the divine will we have to create enough love to conquer that hate. I will follow you from behind
Jesus said and I will come towards you from the front so as to confound you in love.
Of course they're operating in hate and he's operating in love.
And wherever you have banished me I will raise my throne because you can't destroy God.
And there I will reign more than before and in a more astonishing way. So much so that you
yourself would have to fall at the foot of my throne as though bound by the power of my love.
So this means that the greater the opposition given to Jesus the higher he rises, the more
challenge they give him, the more he reaches that challenge and surpasses it because you're dealing
with unconquerable love. That is demonstrated perfectly in the dying of Jesus on the cross.
Indeed during the entire passion the more hatred and destruction that was poured into him the higher
his love rose and accepted everything that was thrown at him and he rose above it and he conquered
them through the very things that they used to destroy him he conquered them.
We're going to have to discover something about this love because it's unconquerable love.
Then he added "Am I daughter? The creature rages more and more in evil. How many machinations
of ruin they are preparing? They will reach the point of exhausting evil itself. But while they
are occupied with following their own way, I will be occupied with making the Fiat Voluntaz tour
come to its completion and fulfillment and my will will reign upon the earth but in a completely
new way because living in the divine will is completely spiritual. There isn't a material
component. We ourselves are the only material component and we have to be transformed into
living hosts and eventually we have to be transformed into light in a completely new way.
I will be occupied with preparing the era of the third Fiat in which my love will show off
in a wondrous and unheard of way. Ah yes I want to confound man completely in love therefore be
attentive. I want you with me. The Lord never does want to do it without us. We have to put
our little drop of water in the wine of his love. We have to put our little drop of water in the wine
of his redemption as well. And I want you with me in preparing this celestial and divine era of love
and we will lend a hand to each other and we'll work together. So I want to give you for that whole
paragraph one John four seven that God is love and Sam 145 verse 17 God only ever acts out of love.
Finally Jesus drew near my mouth Louisa said and as he sent his omnipotent breath into it I felt
new life being infused into me and then he disappeared. So that began in Genesis two seven when God
infused his breath into Adam and you have it in John 20 verse 30 when Jesus breathed upon the apostles
and they became a living church. So February the 16th 1921 in order to enter the divine will
we must do nothing but remove the little stone of our will. So we're back to basics here
and we're back to where we started in volumes one to four and that is our motto is not my will
but thine be done oh Lord and you'll only know the value of that when something crosses your will
not my will but thine be done. And if you're really finding difficulty with that
or if you want to get rid of the problem altogether a prayer that Jesus taught me many many many years
ago is Jesus take me from myself and give me today. I give you permission to actually take me from
myself and give me today. Jesus said my daughter there are neither paths nor doors nor keys to enter
my will so there isn't a whole long list of rules because my will is everywhere it flows under your
feet it's on the right it's on the left it's above your head it's absolutely everywhere the creature
must do nothing but remove the little stone of our own will that's all the more we put down our
own will the more his will rises the more we put down self love the more his love rises it's actually
that simple. The creature has nothing to do but remove the little stone of her own will which
though being in my will does not take part in nor does it enjoy its effects becoming a stranger
in my volition now everything is in the divine will absolutely everything so we're in the divine
will that means our little human will is in the divine will but it doesn't mix with the divine will
only one or the other has to work and so to allow the divine will to work we have to put down the
human will in fact it is as if the little stone of her will prevented the water from flowing
from the shore so as to run somewhere else the stones are blocking it so it's our bits of human
will that's actually blocking the divine will from doing what it wants but if this if the soul
removes the little stone of her will at that very instant it actually doesn't matter whether
you're sitting on top of a mountain or sitting in your bath it actually doesn't matter where you
are at that very instant she flows into me and I into her she finds all my goods at her disposal
she finds strength light and help whatever she wants this is why there are no paths
doors or keys it is enough for her to want it and all is done in other words you open the door
the air comes in it's that simple you pull back the blinds in the morning the light
comes in you remove the obstacle that's all my will takes charge of everything providing her
with all that she lacks and making her wander within the interminable boundaries of my will
it is completely the opposite when you're dealing with just ordinary virtues
how many efforts are needed and how many struggles with yourself and long paths to try and achieve
something and while it seems that the virtue is smiling at her oh just one passion a little
violent one temptation one unexpected encounter and down she is again so in that message Jesus is
telling us straight up get rid of your human will put it aside and let the divine will reign
so let's come back to the third fiat now because the third fiat can't operate
if the human will is in the way so February the 22nd 1921 the third fiat will give such grace
to the creature as to make him return almost to the state of origin i note the word almost
and god will take his perpetual rest in the last fiat
so jesus spoke to louisa and said my daughter it is my usual way to remain silent after i have
spoken because louisa had said to why aren't you saying something he said i want to rest in my own
word that's something that we should do is rest in these messages and also rest in his living word
in the scriptures i want to rest in my own word that is in the very work that came out of me
i did this in creation after i said fiat looks let there be light and light came into be
fiat to all the other things and they also came in to be he said i wanted to rest now that's the
Sabbath rest that you find in the end of the first book of jennises the first chapter of jennises
he said i wanted to rest and my eternal light rested in the light issued in time now god is light
to see one john one five and he said that his eternal light rested in the light that he had put
into our time and space continuum my love rested in the love with which i invested the whole of creation
my beauty rested in the whole universe which i molded after my own beauty
my wisdom and my power rested as well with which i ordered everything
and i ordered it with such wisdom and power that in looking i myself said how beautiful is the work
that came out of me i want to rest in it i do the same with souls he said after i have spoken
i want to rest and enjoy the effects of my word now if you go to matthew chapter 13 you'll meet the
parable of the sore the very first one and you'll see that there are four different responses that
human beings give to the word of god we don't all produce fruit
so after this jesus added let us say fia together and everything in heaven and on earth was filled
with adoration to the supreme majesty then again he repeated fiat and the blood the wounds and the
pains of jesus arose up and multiplied to infinity and then for the third time he said fiat and this
fiat multiplied in all the wills of creatures to sanctify them and then he said to me my daughter
these three fiats are the creating redeeming and sanctifying fiat in the singular because god is one
and three in creating man i endowed him with three powers the intellect the memory and the will
and with three fiats will i accomplish the work of the sanctification of man
at the creating fiat the intellect of man remained as though enraptured how many things he understands
about me and about my love for him as i am hidden inside of all created things in order to make
myself known and to give him love and to be loved love must have its complete cycle it must be given
and received in the fiat of redemption his memory remains as though enchanted by the excesses of my
love in suffering so much in order to help and save man in the state of sin in the third fiat
my love wants to display even more i want to assail the human will i want to place my own will as
support of his will so that the human will may remain not only enraptured and enchanted but
sustained by the eternal will and as my will becomes his support in everything man will almost
be unable to escape it i love the almost we're always free you see he never ever touches that
freedom he has given to us and then he tells us in something very important considering that so
many people on the internet are talking that we have this is the end of the world this is the end
time and so on and so forth it is the end of an era but it's the beginning of the new era of the
new and divine holiness jesus said the generations will not end until my will reigns upon the earth
thanks be to god my redeeming fiat will place itself in the middle between the
creating fiat and the sanctifying fiat they will interweave they will intertwine all three together
and they will accomplish the sanctification of man the third fiat will give such grace to the
creature as to make him return almost to the state of origin and only then when i see man
jostice he came out from me will my work will be complete and then i will take my perpetual rest
the eternal sabbath i will take it in the last fiat only the life of my volition will give
back to man the state of origin so there's no way we can go back to our origin except in and through
the divine will therefore be attentive and together with me helped me to complete the
sanctification of the creature so he wants us to give him our companionship and our acts in the divine
will on hearing this louisa said jesus my love i am not able to do as you do nor indeed as you teach
me and i'm almost afraid of your approaches if i don't do well whatever you want from me
and then jesus said look i also know that you cannot do perfectly what i tell you
but wherever you can't reach i'll make up for you it's absolutely fantastic
he knows that we can't do it properly but he wants us to do it he doesn't want you to make the excuse
that you won't do it because you can only have to it i want to give you sam 103 versus 13 to 14
he knows what we're made of the sam says he knows we're only dust and so he has compassion on us
like a father however jesus said it is necessary that i attract you and that you understand what you
must do so that even if you cannot do everything you must do what you can in other words you must
have your little drop of water in the wine of his redemption you must put your kiss of love
into the fear of uh sanctification you must do what you can and as i speak to you he said your
will remains chained with mine you would like to do what i tell you and i consider this as done
saint taraise of lisue as i've told you before really made a big thing of this when locked up
in her convent she told the lord she wanted to be a priest and a missionary and this and that and
the other so that she could serve him in all of these ways and he said done if you want it i'll do it
so we have to find out what is it we actually want
so louisa said how can this way of living in the divine will be spread and taught to others
now i would imagine that's the the question of the priests
and who would be disposed to it and jesus said my daughter even if nobody had been saved
with my descent upon the earth the work of glorifying the father would already be complete
the same now even if no one wanted to receive this gift which will never be you alone would be
enough and you will give me the complete glory which i want from all creatures now jesus got the
complete and total response for redemption from his mother and he wants the complete and total
response for the fiat of sanctification from louisa and then after our blessed mother
all other christians came afterwards and participated at whatever level they chose
some to a great extent some to a lesser extent it will be the same with the third fiat that all
of us are coming after louisa and we enter into it more or less depending on our desire
to love and serve the lord so as we go into march the second 1921 we have a major change
in louisa's life jesus changes her office completely now he's been guiding her this way
since about volume eight and she has found the change over difficult now he actually announces
what he wants to do jesus changes the state of victim of louisa in order to give her the office
of opening the era of the new and divine holiness so she's put on a completely new path
and you're going to hear him saying in the messages that follow this look let's leave them
outside they want to kill let them kill let them get on with their evil this is completely
different to the way i was before he would come to her showing how wounded he was and ask her to
participate in uh lessening the chastisements and interceding for others now it's going to be
completely different he says let's leave them aside and you and i will create a future full of hope
for them jeremaia 29 11 creating a future full of hope for you so jesus said my daughter the third
fiat my fiat volantis to a secret in chalo at intera will be like the rainbow which appeared
in the sky telling everybody of course that a new era was beginning and that the chastisement
was over that was that was exactly when the rainbow appeared so uh it will be like the rainbow
which appeared in the sky after the deluge now that's genesis 9 15 and i also want to give you
revelation four three and revelation ten one so the new fiat is going to be like this rainbow
showing in the sky after this dreadful purification that must take place on the earth
otherwise this new era can't happen so as the rain it appeared as the rainbow of peace
assuring man that the deluge had ceased now the deluge was the first major purification
of the human race the second one was the passion and death of jesus and the third one will be this
fire from heaven that our lady warned us about infatima jesus said it will be like this for the
third fiat as it comes to be known loving and disinterested souls will come to live in the fiat
and they will be like rainbows rainbows of peace which will reconcile heaven and earth
and will dispel the deluge of so many sins which have inundated the earth why did the deluge come
in genesis it was because of the enormity of sin that was on the planet why is this frightening
chastisement about to fall upon us it's because of the same thing and so the people living in the
divine will are the new rainbows these rainbows of peace will have the third fiat as their own life
and therefore my fiat volantis tour will have its completion in them
and just as the second fiat called me upon the earth to live among them the third fiat will call
my will into souls and it will reign in them on earth as in heaven now if he says it will happen
it will happen because god is truth and then a little bit later louisa said since i was sad
because of his absence jesus added my daughter be cheered come into my will i chose you among
thousands and thousands so my will may have its full completion in you and so that you may be like
a rainbow of peace which with its seven colors attracts others to live in my will so what are these
seven colors if you go to the end of the next message you will find that these seven colors are
love goodness wisdom power sanctity mercy and justice
in other words the divine attributes manifested in us
that you may be like a rainbow of peace which with its seven colors attracts others to live in
my will therefore let us leave the earth aside up until now now watch this now this is is explaining
to her that things are going to be very different so we leave the earth aside it's going to have to
say this a few times to her up until now i've kept you with me in order to appease my justice
and to prevent greater chastisements from being poured upon the earth
now let us allow the current of human evil to run we're going to switch off from it
i want you with me i want to give you a romance one 24 26 and 28 now what do those three verses say
in chapter one of Romans Paul is talking about the cesspool of evil that was in Rome at the time
that Paul was writing and three times he said god abandoned them to their dreadful sin god abandoned
them to the wicked things they were doing god abandoned them you know that's the worst punishment
of all it's much worse than anything else so here Jesus says come on leave let's leave it
let's do something different i want you with me in my volition to be occupied with preparing the
era of my will so again i give you Jeremiah 29 11 for that as you move forward on the path of my
volition the rainbow of peace will form and it will form the link of connection between the divine
will and the human will and from this link my will will have life on the earth and this will begin
the fulfillment of my prayer so louisa is going to make the connection now between heaven and earth
so i really should give you one john no john 151 the ladder between heaven and earth the links that
connect heaven and earth and he says from these links my will will have life on the earth and
this will begin the fulfillment of my prayer and the prayer of the whole church thy kingdom come
thy will be done on earth as it is in heaven now the fulfillment of that kingdom is found in
revelation 21 and 22 and it's after the terrible chastisements that are described in the book of
revelation. So let's leave it there for the moment.